la bandera talibán ya ondea en panshir
la provincia que simbolizó el último
bastión de resistencia contra las
fuerzas del emirato islámico los
talibanes dan la guerra por terminada y
aseguran que inmediatamente se
reanudarán los servicios de internet y
telefonía y volverán a llegar
suministros básicos la región
las fuerzas muy ágiles están
comprometidas con la purga de la
provincia la capital de panshir está
bajo control mujahidin el enemigo sufrió
muchas bajas pero nosotros no tras dos
días el gobierno de la provincia de
panchir está bajo control del emirato
islámico de afganistán
sin embargo el frente nacional de
resistencia de afganistán no reconoce la
derrota la afirmación de los talibanes
de haber ocupado panshir es falsa
las fuerzas del frente nacional de
resistencia están presentes en todas las
posiciones estratégicas del valle para
continuar la lucha le aseguramos al
pueblo de afganistán que la lucha contra
los talibanes y sus socios continuará
hasta que prevalezca la justicia y la
libertad
mientras en kabul sigue la incertidumbre
ante las acciones que tomará el futuro
ejecutivo el portavoz talibán explicó
que habrá que esperar todavía unos días
antes de conocer la composición del
nuevo gobierno alargando la espera del
pueblo afgano y de la comunidad
internacional
los rumores de que hay disputas internas
en el emirato islámico son falsas
estamos intentando agrupar los distintos
consejos y opiniones para establecer un
sistema islámico fuerte y estable en
estos momentos estamos haciendo trabajo
técnico que si dios quiere anunciaremos
pronto vida aprovechando la relación de
qatar con las autoridades talibán as el
secretario de estado de eeuu anthony
blinken se desplazó este lunes a doha
para pedir cooperación en la evacuación
de los estadounidenses y los afganos en
peligro que siguen en el territorio